4 explíquenos en primer lugar Qué
significan estos datos Y cómo pueden
afectar a los bolsillos de las familias
Hola Muchas gracias por la invitación no
los datos están indicando Precisamente
lo que mencionabas recién que
precisamente el nivel de precios ha
bajado un poco los últimos meses pero
todavía está a niveles históricamente
muy elevados al nivel global este y el
producto es de eso es la precisamente la
guerra en Ucrania con la incertidumbre
Que eso genera y aficionado a los
efectos de los aumentos en las tasas de
interés tanto de Estados Unidos como de
Europa que están generando también
cierta incertidumbre en los mercados
respecto a las probabilidades de
reacción tanto en tanto en Estados
Unidos como en Europa Sí con todos estos
factores que usted nos indica además
tras los meses más duros de la pandemia
y con la incertidumbre que sigue
Habiendo en Ucrania gran productor y
exportador de grano el precio de los
alimentos podría seguir en aumento
habrá que ver Precisamente lo que está
ocurriendo en los últimos meses en que
está descendiendo poco a poco
seguramente el de algunos productos
precisamente está bajando por una mayor
oferta porque precisamente es que
aumento de precios hace que ciertos
regiones que adicionalmente no eran
competitivas Ahora sí lo sean como es el
caso de Argentina y Brasil vuelven
ligeramente más competitivos están
empezando a entrar a este mercado
internacional de exportación de granos
que antes no tenían participación porque
precisamente Ucrania Era uno de los
principales productores y era mucho más
competitivo pero con la guerra en
Ucrania ahora estos nuevos países que
empiezan a competir mucho más en estos
mercados entonces seguramente en los
próximos meses seguirá viendo cierta
reducción Aunque seguramente hasta que
no se resuelva el conflicto este
seguramente eso la reducción no vuelva a
los niveles
y adicionalmente digamos que este si a
eso le agregamos los aumentos de tasas
seguramente en la incertidumbre que se
genere en los mercados todavía esos se
traduzca en una mejor en una menor
demanda quizás de algunos productos y
eso pueda llevar quizás a alguna
reducción adicionales en esto en estos
precios a medida que la demanda global
digamos de la economía que se vaya
enfriando poco a poco producto de
facciones de los bancos centrales